and he went up where to take every
single millionaire billionaire wealthy
people that we know and put them in one
room Nauticus be a good-sized room there
you would generally be able to put all
of these successful people in three core
competencies you would say this dude
strength is here
this girl's strength is here this
partnership strength is here that's how
they made it one so let me explain to
what those three core competencies are
number one number one it's somebody who
is extremely technically sound
let me explain to what I mean by someone
I was extremely technical center they
know coding they know laws they know
laws about real estate they know laws
about you know investments they don't
stocks they know charts they know how to
recharge they know how to reach rent
they know how to look at something there
they figure out it certain things in you
maybe not have an addition because
you're not guided extremely technical
exam they can look at a certain you know
projection on an investment on a company
and they'll say no yes what's going on
to the value based company let's buy is
let's builder let's reengineering
let's bring your executive team their
brain as wired as and completed from
wait because they're technically sound
there's second the second type of
competency that we're talking about is
leadership now what is leadership
sometimes the guy that's very technical
it's more about the leadership side and
some time together
good as leadership maybe afforable on
the technical side usually someone who
looks from the outside and says you know
what we need pretty deaf person here
bring this person here and this
department needs to be here this person
was going to drive in this part here we
need this department on this side here I
want to be able to bring that guy here
let me try to recruit this other column
and come here because they know how to
lead an army they know how to lead a
team they're not to put a strong team to
get in the last one the third one I'm a
30-month on the core competency it's not
technical if not leadership
its strategic strategic competencies
people who not have put deals together
they'll look at it and say I want to
take 25% of this year on the real estate
deal and let's bring this person in with
the money and let's create this
partnership here and if we sell it by
this time we'll be able to sell it out
high they're all strategy it slightly
different
leadership strategic is slightly
different than leaders with because
leadership has more people you're very
good with people you're very good at
driving people strategy has to do with
timing partnerships you know teaming up
with somebody the enemy the competition
when we take them out of what we
announce to come what do we announce
this launch won't be announced this
initiative that's strategy very very
different and by the way if you can find
yourself in a situation on a team
whether it's a technical there's a
leader and there's the deal the
strategic you put them together now
you're talking about a powerhouse team
that can be really well my message to is
very simple here for my message through
it you're not going to be able to do all
three or no one's going to be opening I
do make sure what miss personal is good
at all three of them that person
everybody typically has one port that
they'll get up and by the way just
because you may be watching the same on
very good strategy I'm going to get out
initial immersion at technical coding
that still doesn't mean gonna be
millionaire because I don't know your
work yet I got all your fire I don't
know your desire I don't know your
willingness to get up and get to work in
go for yours and you know handling
pressure and all that other stuff I'm
assuming you're willing to do that I'm
sorry you're willing to do that if
you're willing to do that these are
three core competencies one of them's
got of your technical leadership or
strategic and then from there you're not
a shadow one day being a millionaire
entrepreneur yourself as well not you
got any questions kind of styles be sure
to comment on the bottom and if you
haven't subscribed to this channel be
sure to subscribe to voluminous or
like
[Music]